one afternoon a mother is cooking lunch
for her six-year-old daughter while she
plays in the back everything seems to be
normal until the mother turns towards
the sink and sees that it is black and
ashy that sink needs some lotion she
takes more than a second to comprehend
what she is seeing then starts looking
around the kitchen to her utter surprise
the entire place looks to be burnt down
like an aftermath of a bad fire her
instincts maker quickly turned towards
your daughter but the little girl who
was there only a second ago is missing
the mother panics and runs towards the
bedroom only to meet with another
surprise her six-year-old has gone back
in time and turned into her
three-year-old self alongside the room
which is also changed into its older
form the mother Cries Out Loud and runs
outside the house to see a group of
people watching her apartment building
in awe like the kitchen the entire
building seems to be burnt but without
fire it seems as if the whole town is
teleported to a few years back because
the exact same fire accident has taken
place in the past suddenly the building
flickers and the people gasp everything
starts coming back to normal right after
the little girl turns back into her
six-year-old self the residents do not
waste time before calling the police to
investigate the abnormal activities then
we are introduced to an FBI detective
Olivia she and her team investigate the
scene and realize that some parts of the
house are completely fine without the
trace of any burn marks while the others
are fully destroyed by a fire upon
looking at several records of the place
they also discovered that the building
had caught fire three years ago and
looked exactly how it looks currently it
is almost as if some parts of it
teleported back in time this theory is
supported by the mother from earlier who
reveals that her daughter was three
years old when the last fire occurred
and she too teleported in time earlier
detective Olivia is intrigued but not
shocked by the situation this is because
she has witnessed such activities
several times in the last week they use
a special neuro radiation device around
the place if the levels are high it
means the surroundings have traveled or
will travel through time at night in
another part of the city a group of
youngsters are driving through a forest
to a party it is a casual night until
suddenly a moving train appears in front
of their car they immediately stop
closely avoiding crashing with the train
upon getting out they see the train
flickering and then disappearing
entirely the group is left stunned with
no way to confirm what they just saw but
they can all agree they should probably
stop smoking that Sheba the following
day Olivia's colleague detective Peter
hears the news about the Train's
appearance he gets ready to walk out of
the station and a second later magically
appears in the location other police
officers are working on the scene but do
not notice him appearing out of thin air
a confused Peter barely knows how he got
here and continues investigating he
seems to have time traveled as the house
did earlier Olivia is also at the scene
talking to the guy who saw the train he
vows that he wasn't high and confirmed
seeing a sphere bubble around the train
when it passed this is especially
strange because the track was closed
three years ago and no train is passed
through it since Peter checks this
around findings with a neuro radiation
testing device and sees the front part
of the youngster's car has changed
because it touched the bubble around the
train last night the bumper is so
delicate that when Peter touches it a
piece crumbles into his hands Peter
turns around to tell his colleagues
about the car when suddenly he appears
inside a car driving to the railway
location with them he understands that
he traveled into the future when he was
walking out of the station earlier and
has returned to the original time now
the phenomenon is strange and Peter has
no clue why it's happening to him but he
refrains from asking for help from
Olivia when his colleagues notice the
change in his demeanor they ask him what
is wrong Peter recovers by telling them
that their car has high levels of neuro
radiation This is highly unnatural which
means these time events are being caused
by some kind of human technology Olivia
hardly believes Peter but she has
nothing else to work with at the moment
the scene cuts to a house Professor Kate
is passionately working on building an
equation like she does every day a
freaking nerd for the past decade she
has been working to develop a device
that travels through time and and in
recent years she is very close to
developing a principal formula for it
her husband Raymond loves his wife and
supports her in all of her decisions but
doesn't like that she overworks herself
he comes towards her looking at the
timer in his watch strangely enough he
holds Kate endearingly and wishes her
goodbye less than a second later she
disappears from his arms and her work
from the wall is also gone Raymond
simply walks into the living room like
he was expecting that to happen
surprisingly enough Kate is on the sofa
staring at the wall when her husband
tries to feed her she jerks away asking
him who he is it is then revealed that
Kate has Alzheimer's and the person
Raymond was talking to earlier was her
from the past when she first started
losing her senses Kate was very close to
creating a time machine however she
failed because the disease got the best
of her Raymond was devastated when his
wife stopped recognizing him and wanted
to get her back to normal one day he got
his hands on her research and found a
way to turn back time he worked hard for
a year and proved that Kate's study was
successful he could now make their home
go back in time but only for 47 minutes
currently it is 2021 but the house Kate
and Raymond live in is mostly in 2017
when Kate is still healthy the reason
strange time-related occurrences are
happening throughout the city is also
because of the same thing when Raymond
bent time for the first time it left an
unnatural amount of neural radiation in
different parts of the city which is why
they have been going back and forth in
time for the past month somewhere else
Peter Olivia and their colleagues are
trying to find a relationship between
the locations of the time shifts that
have occurred up until now after looking
at the map for hours they realized that
the occurrences follow fibonacci's
golden spiral this means that they are
all friggin nerds
this means that they should check areas
that fall in the three square miles area
of the center to find the source of the
abnormalities back in the house Raymond
takes care of Kate who frantically talks
about going out to shop for Christmas
Raymond cannot handle his wife being so
out of touch with reality and decides to
bend time again he walks into the
basement which he has turned into his
lab it contains several failed devices
and projects proving how hard he has
worked for the past years he walks up to
the machine that actually works and
presses a few buttons this starts the
machine and sets the timer for the next
47 minutes their entire house will go
back to being in 2017. Raymond goes back
up and sees his wife working on her
research once again this time she smiles
at him and asks him to take his pills
the man has walked up to her doing the
same thing several times but his heart
still skips a beat when he hears her
talking normally they joke around like a
normal couple at the same time Peter and
Olivia start their search for the center
of the Spiral they locate several houses
and ask the residents if they have
noticed anything strange happening
around the area most people report
having a feeling of deja vu but nothing
significant is found a few minutes into
the search Peter's friend reaches close
to Raymond and Kate's residence as he
walks onto the lawn he bursts into Ash
and disappears this is because any
sudden appearance in the time field
messes with the subject and crushes it
Olivia sees her friend disappearing and
quickly contacts the rest of the group
in the next few minutes an entire team
of Agents appears in front of the house
looking for a way to get inside Raymond
notices the cars approaching from the
window and starts to panic he wants to
turn the machine off but if it is done
hastily it might ruin the entire fabric
of space-time moreover once the machine
is turned on Raymond doesn't have the
formula to turn it off as he has been
letting it run fully until now now the
only way to not get caught is to make
the time shift permanent and for that
Raymond needs his wife's help he pulls a
confused Cade into the basement and
frantically shows her around she doesn't
remember anything about the future hence
the place and her husband's ramble
confuse use her then finally Raymond
tells her that he worked for three years
on her project and made a time machine
he calls her a genius and asks her to
help him make it permanent so they can
live together forever Kate still
confused about everything claims that
her project was supposed to remain a
theory because she never wanted to break
the rules of nature however Raymond
argues that she has done a lot for him
in her life and the only way for him to
give back to her is by Saving her the
entire rest of the population of the
world be damned his words freeze Kate
and she asks what will happen to her in
the future she finds out about the
Alzheimer's disease but still wants
Raymond to stop the time travel outside
Olivia comes close to the house and
sprays a chemical on it in the correct
lighting a giant time bubble can be seen
covering the entire property Olivia
doesn't dare walk inside having seen
what happened to her colleague earlier
simultaneously Peter continues studying
the areas around the house to predict
where the next time relapse is going to
take place through his horror the very
next area targets an underground ground
tunnel that did not exist four years ago
if the time relapse occurs and the
tunnel disappears hundreds of people
inside it would drown and die one of
them immediately runs to get the area
evacuated while the others continue
trying to get into the house to stop the
machine in the following scene Peter's
scientist friend builds a magnetic vast
that reflects the radiation when one is
inside the time zone Olivia argues that
she wants to go inside but Peter who has
a scientific background is tasked with
the job everyone holds their breath when
he takes the first step inside the
bubble thankfully the vest works and he
simply walks into the house will his
sperm ever be the same though he soon
finds the basement but is hit in the
head before turning the machine off Kate
doesn't approve of her husband doing
such things but Raymond argues that he
is doing all of this for her at the same
time the tunnel inside the river starts
disappearing people watching awe as
water starts flowing in disobeying every
rule of physics back at the house the
husband and wife get into an argument
because Kate doesn't want him to throw
his life away living in a bubble with
her they do not notice Peter waking up
in the background and are shocked when
he points a bat at them he tries turning
the machine off but is stopped because
turning it off in a hurry would mean a
rip in the fabric of space-time Peter
tells the couple about the tunnel and
how hundreds of people are going to die
if the machine continues working Kate
immediately agrees to turn it off but
only if her husband won't be prosecuted
for his deeds in the time of emergency
Peter prioritizes people's lives and
agrees to negotiate the terms with the
officials when there are only one and a
half minutes left on the machine and the
tunnel is about to flood Kate completes
the equation the time bubble around the
house disappears the tunnel is saved and
Kate goes back to being sick the
following day the house is cleared up
and as per the negotiation Raymond is
set free to be a lunatic elsewhere after
everything ends he goes back to Kate's
book hoping to try and rebuild the
formula again however he sees that she
has painted over the formula to disallow
him for making the same mistake again in
the final scene Raymond reads a message
where Kate asks him to repay her by by
loving her and living his life fully
good thing Raymond has a crap memory
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching